you know we we got people who are in
high places
that
you know that has done four works if you
look at it realistically and you know
they still up there so at the same this
is small potatoes a lot of things out
there but at the same time is a big
issue in in america today
was not as in football whether or not
it's in everyday life or not it's in
politics it's out there
that's doug williams the washington
senior vp of player personnel speaking
on the team 980 in washington on
thursday and
i wonder what his brain was telling him
as his words
were being articulated and formed small
potatoes is it small potatoes a second
domestic violence arrest in the same
calendar year and the first one
ultimately went nowhere because the
alleged victim recanted which happens
far too often in situations like this
even if there was violence that occurred
the alleged victim decides that
her affection for the aggressor
overcomes any desire to see him get in
trouble especially since it may choke
off a significant supply of
of revenue so it's it's not small
potatoes
and i don't know who's refer i think i
know who he's referring to
um but uh regardless of what anyone else
has done that doesn't justify what
reuben foster did look washington made a
calculated decision to take a flyer on
reuben foster and to take any heat that
would come along with it i think they
underestimated the amount of heat that
would come along with it and they
probably should have listened to whoever
from the league office was telling them
just wait until this all gets resolved
there's no reason to make a waiver claim
for this guy and if you choose to sign
with someone else once this is all
cleared up so be it you don't need to
pay the guy 250 000
to not play for you this year just so
you have dibs on him for next year this
is going to be a problem for everyone
and it has been it's crossed over to
mainstream news outlets and it was a
huge mistake by washington and the fact
that they put doug williams out there
yesterday was probably another mistake
even though they felt like they had to
do it because so many people in
washington are saying where are the
people in the front office who made this
decision so they can still undo the
decision and i won't be shocked if they
do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports